Drive by day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night,
all day.
That's what you want to do.
Both of them.
I know that.
And then he can't lie to me.
There's nothing you're going to lie
to me about because if you lie to me,
I'm gonna see you on Monday,
idiot,
and we're going to see
what you're made of.
You'll know anyway.
I mean,
without even knowing what they're made of,
you'll know their mind.
But it's different when
you fight somebody,
you literally know what they're made of.
When you see the look in their eye and
they say what they say and they do what
they do and then they go and they fight
and they don't say what they say and
they don't do what they do.
And that's just fighting.
And that's what's so
refreshing about it to me.
Yeah.
Well the psychological aspect of it,
I mean,
you know,
well,
who was it that said this fighting is 90%
mental and the other 10% in your head?
I forget who said that.
I remember either,
but I've heard it.
That's a great quote.
I remember who said it,
but I mean it's,
I believe it with all my heart.
There's so many people out there,
there's so incredibly physically talented.
And how many gym assassins do you know
that for whatever reason they just can't
put it together when the referee
says are fine or are you ready,
finery ready go.
They just are a fraction
of who they really are.
Just really break down and think about
what happens to the ones that do make it
and then have to deal
with the media and uh,
opinions.
And I really feel like athletes,
the biggest hurdle is effect.
That we're willing to actually
just get up there and say we might,
when we might lose.
And just put that out there and say,
are you willing to,
to put yourself out there like that.
Are you willing to embarrass
yourself if you do lose?
Are you willing to deal with the media?
If you win for 10 years straight and then
lose and then now you're the worst guy
that's ever been seen in the sport or the
worst female that's ever been seen the
sport you didn't even belong.
There,
are you able to deal with that?
That's the question.
That's what being an athlete is not.
Well those would be an fighter being
different strains to basketball game.
It's true.
You lose a basketball game and people
might think you're a fucking loser or a
scrub,
but it's nothing like the shit
that I see fighters face online.
No,
I mean,
just look at,
I gotta bring Ronda Rousey up because
it's heartbreaking for me as an athlete.
I know what she's feeling,
I know what she's going through.
And um,
as a female it's even on another level,
I can't really imagine that.
I just,
it's a different level of
scrutiny I would imagine.
But um,
it's just,
it shows how hard it is
to deal with this man,
the,
the ups and downs because the downs
hit hard just as hard as it hit and you
gotta be ready and there can't be any
separation and who you are with a win and
a loss.
Because if there is,
it's going to shell and you gotta be who
you are and not be solely connected to
fighting as your whole being.
Otherwise you're over when,
when it,
when it ends,
right.
There was something about the Ronda
Rousey promos that I always felt like I
just,
I didn't like hearing it.
Like she was like,
I gotta get back to fighting because
it's the most important thing and it's a
thing that I can be best in the world.
And I was like,
Ooh,
I actually like hearing that studio.
I do.
And the reason is,
it's such a lesson if you really listening
in between the lines to the issue of
the world.
And that's just my opinion.
We're all putting so much into this
one thing and we think that that is our
everything when really if she,
Eh,
it sounds cheesy,
but if you put all that energy towards
loving yourself and not the fight career,
the fight career will still be
there just as heavy as it is.
Right.
You know?
So what I mean is she's using the
fighting as her identity with that
championship belt.
She is Ronda Rousey,
the Ronda Rousey without
the championship belt.
We don't know who she is.
She won't come out.
So who are you?
Unless you're winning.
We don't know.
Do you know?
You're counting on that belt
to know who you are now?
And that's,
that was my biggest point.
That was a hurdle I ran
into when I lost my belt.
I didn't know who I was anymore,
and that's how I knew this.
That's how I figured
out what my issues were.
[inaudible]
yeah.